ready here we go and three
two hello and welcome to whatever
episode this is of congratulations
[Music]
hey guys what's cracking man knock him
out the box rick
knock him out rick
music you can't sing and i just proved
them wrong
actually said hum never mind um mm-hmm
wow i remember that remember the [ __ ]
ghost face killer thing that
the daytona 5 5000 or whatever the [ __ ]
and it would be like
and i was so pissed that the beat never
dropped even harder than that
and that's it that's the whole story
sometimes they tell bad stories but
they're very quick and that's how bad
stories should be
all right
started off taking me out um you know
what i
uh things are cool man i want to say
you know uh thank you so much for
listening and
uh and you guys are so sweet i see you
guys making friends in those comments
i see you guys uh you know whining and
dying in that subscribe button
and we love it dude we love it when you
whine and dine that subscribe button
dude we absolutely love it take the like
button to the park
and absolutely go see a movie with the
when you
with the [ __ ] bell notifications we
love it we love it we're dating the
[ __ ] clicks we're dating the things
that you click on instead of smashing
them and destroying them like all other
youtubers say
we do it different baby dude then
yeah i'm different um
so yeah dude we're chilling and uh it's
a good thing and the the
patreon support is nice it keeps coming
it keeps rolling it keeps rolling
rolling rolling
and uh besides that if you're not on the
patreon get on board
chris uh patreon.com slash crystalia and
couldn't [ __ ] that up even more
and uh it's patreon.com and if you're
not thanks for even watching on youtube
uh the even though you don't get the
full episode you get the you get the the
cut up episode
but you get the freaking uncut episode
in the patreon dude
um yeah dude it's the yellow shirt
podcast wasn't sure about the shirt
and still not sure and kristen said it
was good
scentsy and it's all good but i'm
chilling so
what are we talking about here man we're
having a good time i had a good day you
know
was uh was super mad yesterday and was
super not mad today
some days you get mad some days you
you're less mad
and both of those days life rips right
both of those days life rips because
both of those days
you wake up and both of those days you
get through it
and you go to sleep and then you wake up
and do it all over again
so uh that's it man um and
it's been really it's been it it was
really sh [ __ ] yesterday and it's been
really good today
i'll tell you why actually yesterday
was annoying as f oh man i was so angry
and really trying to sit and deal with
my emotion just really trying to just
sit and
huh why do i feel this way but not able
to just
rest heart pumping couldn't get it
together i uh my phone all of a sudden
decided to just be like
hey i know you're not touching the
screen but it doesn't matter i'm just
going to act like you're touching the
screen and i'm going to act like you're
on coke while doing it
all of a sudden my screen was just going
flipping around flipping flipping around
opening apps
almost posted [ __ ] that i didn't want to
post almost having a [ __ ] heart
attack
i would just open up instagram and put
this on open up this and put that on
and i'm like jesus christ sign me up for
linkedin wasn't touching
[ __ ] dude
it's called i looked it up it's called
ghost touch sounds like a [ __ ] mi
movie
tom cruise mission impossible nine
ghost touch starring definitely also
so it was doing the ghost touch thing
and it was
not mildly annoying it was mach 11
annoying
it was mach 11. all of a sudden phone
starts
opening up [ __ ] and so i'm like all
right i guess i got to get a new phone
right
got to get a new phone so i go in
and to the so i go into no so i order it
so i order it online so it's ready for
me when i pick it up at the apple store
okay that's how it's supposed to be we
live in the future
this is how it's supposed to be 2021 you
order it online
you saunter in you go where's my iphone
my name's chris
it should be for me oh you got it ready
already cool put in your cargo pants and
moon walk the [ __ ] out apple
alright so that's what is supposed to
happen
and apple agrees with that by the way so
great apple
we're both on the same page
so i order it and it says boom email
flung
it's ready come pick it up and all of a
sudden i'm johnny drives it cool
just driving all the way down to the
[ __ ] uh
mall in sherman oaks like i'm like i
want to go
and i'm like i haven't been to the mall
since [ __ ] covert hit
so i go and i park
and i walk in the mall now did i walk in
close to the apple store or did i walk
in
as far as possible and then i have to
walk the whole mall and realize i could
have parked closer
you do the math guess have you ever have
you ever by mistake
parked to the place that you meant to
go if you want to go to [ __ ] the food
court
maybe if you want to go to food court
because there are signs from it from
outside and you can kind of sense where
it is from the outside
right there's lots of like pigeons
outside
but if you want to go to the apple store
and it's not bloomingdales or macy's
right because those are on the edges
always but in the middle
all the other [ __ ] orange julius [ __ ]
apple
always a j crew in the mall if you don't
have a j crew in the mall
you ain't [ __ ] unless you have a banana
republic but if you're a great mall
you got em both okay
walked in i go where's the apple store
immediately my mall senses started
tingling
and i walked directly where i wasn't
because life doesn't work out that way
it's always far out so i go to the i'm
walking and i'm walking and i'm just
sensing and then i look on the [ __ ]
you are here thing and
sure enough i was the furthest possible
play the apple store was all the way at
the end
if you've been to the [ __ ] sherman
oaks mall you know this
so i'm like good can't wait to get my
phone got my email now can i access the
email
no because the ghost touch is happening
on my phone apps are opening and
shutting
and it's very annoying
so i'm like they better not ask me for
[ __ ] dude
i better just walk in and they better
just give it to
hopefully this is one of those things
where fame is like oh yeah i know who
you are of course
here you go here's your iphone is it too
much to ask
or if i was a [ __ ] emotional italian
i say is it too much to x
and um
so i go in and i say hey hi
first of all why are they dressed like
like
regular people that don't work there hey
apple get it together
dude you have employees put a [ __ ]
uniform on them if i go anywhere else in
the world
they all got uniforms they all look the
same when i walk into apple
i'm like hey
are you all customers or what's
happening
you either all work here or none of you
work here because you don't look
different at least dress them up like
all the movies in the future or some
[ __ ]
like have them all look at like
demolition man or something
that's what they do they got the eye the
[ __ ] apple dudes in the back just
frozen until they defrost them and
they're like you're a genius go out
there and fix computers
there's no i don't know how long it's
been a long time since i've been to an
apple store
there's no desk anymore there's no
counter they're just there
chilling with their hands in their
pockets and a little mechanism that's
like what do you need
and you're like airpods come with me
here i'm gonna get george sketch in here
george grab an airpod
they throw him out george comes he like
does the thing where he [ __ ] bounces
off his elbow and then the other guy
catches it here you go want me to ring
you up you want an email to you and
you're out
i want a counter in the [ __ ] store
okay otherwise i don't know where the
[ __ ] i am it's like what it's like i'm
at it's like i'm at
sea i might as well be at sea and
someone's like where's du
east and i'm like i don't know that's
what i feel like i'm in the apple store
and everyone no one's dressed like a
captain
so i'm like hey do you work here yeah
and they're like
uh-huh and i'm like cool man hey um so i
i got it uh thing and the and it
and uh i ordered it and the phone should
be ready
and the and the guy goes oh cool let me
get uh
a different person uh to take i'm like
all right whatever
so this lady comes by and she's like hey
what's up how can i help you and i was
like
just just told this guy it's all good
but it um so i
um so i ordered an iphone and it said
and it said it's ready
and uh so i just want to come in here my
my phone's doing the ghost touch thing
and she says oh isn't that annoying and
i said
yeah but it's all good just came here to
get a new phone and she says okay cool
uh let me look you up what's your name
and i go
you know my name
inside my head but outside i said it's
chris it's crystalia and she says okay
uh and she types it in and she says
hmm blood level rises
there should be no in the transaction
i came here you give me the phone i'm
out already paid
no reason to go hmm
so she does the noi that noise and i
say what what's up and she says
so did you get um an email uh
confirming that it was ready and in my
head
while she said that in my head not out
loud
but in the middle of her saying that in
my head
i went yo
[Laughter]
and i snapped out of it like the old
ally mcbeal i want to do that [ __ ]
so badly now did you get the yup
i play by the rules
and i do dude oh when i do
and you know that if you listen to this
podcast because i don't want it to be my
fault i want it to be someone else's
fault
so i say uh yeah i got it yeah i got the
email it says it's ready she says oh
okay can you show me and i said nah my
phone's got ghost touch going on and she
says so right yeah
yeah yeah yeah so but it's ready and she
says okay well
let me look okay okay well let me go in
the back now they're in the back
she's in the back with two other guys
they're trying to figure this [ __ ] out
now am i pissed of course but i'm
keeping it cool my baby i'm keeping it
really really cool
my blood level is activated but i'm
using the technique that i'm using
through all of my therapies
and it's getting down it's getting down
my ocd is
quelling everything's fine i've got a
beautiful son
i've got the partner of a lifetime my
mom and dad are healthy
and my brother's cooler than i am so i'm
like
smooth sailing chris just stare at that
big ass
apple tv that that they got [ __ ]
showing
rihanna or billy eilish or whatever the
[ __ ]
just be a customer a cool as a cucumber
customer
and so i'm waiting and they come back
out and they're like
so
and when you say and so
and you're somebody who has my [ __ ]
like wolverine right but in my head
though i wanted to go
oh here we go
in my head i was doing it all day long i
was singing opera in my [ __ ] head
but i'm keeping it cool as a cucumber
and i say yes what's the problem and she
says
well you know i'm so is somebody that
and they say another name
why does it say it's for this person and
i say oh right that's my business
manager when i order something on apple
pay
it goes to him i don't know why his name
is on that he probably doesn't know
either but when i set it up
sometimes i send things to him and then
it sends it she says okay all right okay
well let's
you know what we'll be right back she
goes back in the back now i'm like
there's got to be a [ __ ] something
something real fun going back there
because you're coming back and forth too
many times figure it all out while
you're back there
and then come back and tell me what's
going on this back and forth [ __ ]
there's some in there in that back room
that's going on that you're not telling
me about
and i'm missing out on a lot of fun okay
because you're working which is what you
should be doing
but you keep going back to that room and
that must be where the party's at
you understand it keeps drawing me back
in
that room is cocaine yeah i try to leave
but i'm addicted
so the lady comes out of the cocaine
room and she says
well and now i'm pissed because you hit
the
hmm so and well
and those are the three [ __ ] that's
the three
that's that hairy carry right there
bowels spilling out over macaque
right so
now that i'm sitting there imaginarily
singing opera and having the bowels
laid out all over from [ __ ] right now
that my
entrails are laid out cascading over
balls okay
i'm like here we go and she says we're
not allowed to give it to you
now i'm already the good thing is i'm
already dead i'm dead inside
i'm already dead and i already realized
i lost the battle
and it's fine the old me would have been
like phone's mine so what are we gonna
do about this how are we going to get
this out
how are we going to get this phone out
of that back room and out of this apple
store
and out of this westfield mall and out
of my car
and back into my home because it's mine
but i'm cool i'm johnny cools it down
i'm cooling it way down
i'm johnny frostbite right now
okay inside i'm mad but i'm also johnny
frostbite okay she doesn't know anything
that's going on in my body
so i say to her okay well why don't you
tell me what's going on and she says
when you ordered it you ordered it with
the other person's name and technically
that's the only person who can come pick
it up is he close and i go
in my head no and even if he was he's
not coming it's my phone i'm not gonna
bother my business manager
hey could you leave your work and come
[ __ ] get my iphone for me
number one because it's rude and weird
and number two
is in florida yeah yeah
give me nine hours she'll get a direct
flight
so she's like so what could we do can he
call and cancel that and can
ca and and can we and i'm just like just
i'll buy one now
so i bought one then
immediately i bought one then hey dog
shut up incel shut up oh shut up shut up
shut up nothing's happening dude dogs
are barking and nothing's happening
that's great man
my dogs are doing the [ __ ] iphone
equivalent of a ghost touch nothing's
happening
i say as mercenaries come in and just
shoot up the whole place
i hope they get the dogs first anyway so
i can die in silence um
so now i'm like i'll just buy it i'll
get the thing or whatever so i get the
phone
and i already [ __ ] picked out which
one i wanted with all the gigabytes and
[ __ ] like that
so i'm like all right now i gotta do
this whole thing over again at least i'm
here and they could talk about any
problems because hey
you know what they're [ __ ] geniuses
they call themselves
geniuses so that's what they are
and i say oh yeah let me just buy one
now and she says okay cool i'll be right
back so now she goes back in the [ __ ]
cocaine room
and the [ __ ] and another guy comes
out
and he says hey you want you want to you
were the one that wanted to purchase an
iphone
and i was like yeah okay cool and he
says okay
which one do you want and i was like why
are you
i already told the other the other first
two people but um i i want the uh
12 pro not the max because i don't like
the big one
because i don't need a computer i need a
phone and he says okay great
so the big one but johnny cools it down
you weren't listening but johnny cools
it down right
i mean the guy's getting so [ __ ] he's
getting way ahead of us he's not even
listening he sells so much [ __ ] he's
probably mixing me up with a customer he
had five weeks ago
so i'm pissed off but johnny air
conditioning right
i mean i'm [ __ ] pissed off and i'm
hot but it's like johnny lemonade on a
hot warm day
right a hot summer day johnny lemonade
on a hot summer day
that's who i am right now okay
so anyway the guy's like okay and what
color do you want and i say
not the white um i see him all in person
now i said you know i'll get the gold
one and he says okay
she was like and what size do you want
and i said the biggest and he said
so that's 200 and yada yada and i said
no
no that's not the biggest i want the
biggest and he says though that's the
biggest
and i go like
i'm not the genius here okay
do some more looking and he goes oh oh
no
it's 500 something gig and i go oh
so we we figured that out great so he
says okay great so
iphone i swear to god he says iphone 12
pro max and i say
i'm gonna take a [ __ ] right here sir
in my head and he's like okay no so he
brings the phone out and he says great
so do you want to set it up here or do
you want to oh no he says
you want to to bring it home
now i don't know what that [ __ ]
question means because i want the phone
set it up and i also want to
[ __ ] bring it home so i said what's
the difference and he said will you
either set it up here or you set it up
when you get home
and i said well i'm here why don't i set
it up here and he says okay
and he says well it's it i i he
definitely wanted me to take it home
he's like you take it home you open up
out of the box it's just
[ __ ] it's all ready and i say oh but
don't have to like transfer everything
and he's like
yeah but you know you can do it it's
easy and i was like okay
and then he's like uh so you want to s
so i said how do i transfer everything
and he's like you just take your old
phone and transfer the [ __ ] and i said
can i do that here and he says oh you
can do it here but you say you want to
take it home and i was like okay
so how long does it take he said i don't
know an hour i said oh [ __ ] i'll do it
at home he says well i mean it can take
an hour but it could be shorter i said
don't matter i'll take it at home so i
go home i bring it home
right i bring it home i bring it i bring
it right here and i [ __ ] go to do it
i tried five times tried five [ __ ]
times
and it said it was gonna take three
hours and 45 minutes each time and each
time after 25 minutes
it said no can't do it there's too much
[ __ ] on one phone to give it to the
other phone
which makes no sense because bullets a
song both of the phones were the biggest
okay so now i'm so mad and i'm really
trying to i'm johnny close it down but
i'm not johnny closer to that anymore
i'm johnny i'm johnny i'm johnny heat is
rising okay
and and i'm like
they didn't work five times and i'm
doing this for three hours and then i
drive back in the meantime my other
phone is not working i'm probably
getting so many job offers and missing
out on them
somebody called me and like hey crystal
you're back and i didn't know about that
my old age goes hey we wanted to hire
you again oh we want you to hire
us again oh really oh [ __ ] i miss it all
so i go back
and i'm like hey man it didn't work and
the guy's like really what
a different guy now what oh no really
another guy comes over really it should
work
yeah no [ __ ] and i [ __ ] and he's like
do you want us to transfer it i'm like
nah i'll just do it you know what i'm
just gonna start getting fed up i'm
gonna start from scratch so now i got a
phone
start from scratch no photos no nothing
i got all this [ __ ] my old phone i got
no contact no nothing dude
i had to download all the apps again
it's [ __ ]
make it easy apple make it easy the
story was too long but what i'm saying
is make it
easy dude boom boom boom boom we're in
the future you don't work
and about four of those [ __ ] tags too
those [ __ ] um
tags that you stick to things and you
could find [ __ ] so i'm not gonna lose
[ __ ] anymore dude i'm gonna put one on
calvin
um so i got a new phone and that's great
i should be grateful you know what i
mean it's not like i'm i'm
it's just like first world problems
i know there's like no running water in
india and [ __ ] and the haitian president
just got assassinated
which is really really [ __ ] up you
know but it's like
transfer my iphone quicker you know what
i'm saying
i mean i know the haitian president just
[ __ ] took one of the head but
fix my iphone quicker i don't want to
talk to these many people
when i'm there the second time i went to
the apple store though i brought
i brought calvin and i brought kristen
and calvin was hilarious there dude
he was hilarious there and his little
shorts and shirt and he was just like
is he was so he was just like
what is this he saw the big screen and
he's like
like showing me [ __ ] like i'm like bro
i've been live
you're the new one i'm showing you okay
i brought you here i'm showing you the
whole thing don't act like you're
showing me pieces of the place
i brought you to the whole place
beats headphones tata i know i have four
of them
i got him on right now i mean this is
the same ones in the podcast room thank
you calvin i'm trying to deal with one
of the geniuses
pointing ariana on the [ __ ] apple
music thing
i know about rihanna's son but it was so
cute dude
and then we took him to the food court
and he ate chicken and almost choked
twice
um
but i'm you know oh let's watch this
dude
this is [ __ ] hilarious
i don't know how the [ __ ] i never seen
this it's a million views and this was
sent to me
let me actually find out who it was sent
by
uh because somebody on the discord sent
it to me
it was mac delicious
change it but thank you in the segment
ideas of the discord
and if you're a [ __ ] producer tier
person then you get to
pitch segment ideas and he sent me this
mac delicious change it thank you but
also
sent this great clip looks like my
friend jonathan sadowski
in this video and it's called 21 foot
rule less talk and more action
already you know whoever labeled this
anyone says let's talk more action if
it's not like the rock
you have an office job and you think
you're way [ __ ] doper than you really
are okay so
so this is the video this guy and it
starts with a guy an image of a guy
holding a [ __ ] samurai knife it's
like
short but also way too long to be a
knife
just trying to make you gun guys aware
of a gun guys try to make you gun guys
about uh aware about the abilities are
of the knife because
you move too slow and you count too much
on that one shot taking him down
and you got to move dude first of all
the glasses that he's wearing
are so wire rim it looks like that it
looks like [ __ ] they belong to peter
griffin
like they're so not there and they're
oval
these are the worst glasses i've ever
seen in my life to be honest these are
the worst glasses i've ever seen in my
life
and the guys wearing them like they're
[ __ ] oakleys the most badass shits
badass shits ever okay
and the house is his house has all brick
in the background which is hilarious in
itself okay
gets up it's 21 feet 21 i don't know
what the 21 feet he stays 21 feet away
from someone
[ __ ] wow jean shorts ran up and [ __ ]
lopped the head off of a homemade
dummy a cardboard dummy all right so
[ __ ] you heard his keys jingling when
he was running you know
that's the best part you heard jingling
when running
running for your life in a [ __ ]
combat scenario
with keys
and already out of breath at the end
he's running like this
oh came back oh wow jumped up and down
trees somewhere and i see somebody
coming down the trip
behind a tree somewhere hold on i gotta
go back here
what did he say i'm hiding behind a tree
somewhere and i see somebody coming down
the trail and i go huh
that's my enemy
and i go that's my enemy
no soldier or warrior
has ever said huh there's my enemy
that's like a guy who has no enemies
that's just creating enemies
dude this guy guys with weapons
you know like if you want to have a go
i'm not
against owning a gun if you know how to
operate it
properly but you just need one dude
or two but don't have like all the
all these weapons if you're a guy who
has like a wall of weapons
it's so so you're mixed up dude
you don't need to have a wall of weapons
do you know why
because you're just you right because
why because you work where
at office depot cause why you work where
huh there's my enemy almost felt when
you
ran your duck would duck
with duck all right this is a relatively
small
so close to the camera it's the uh cold
steel spartan
just hanging out oh
just hanging out just hanging out
oh the anger dude
just hanging out
i like how he's doing our work for us
he's
playing what we're thinking in our head
huh that guy's just hanging out
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa thank god
he gave me 21 feet
run dude how can somebody be real like
this
is unreal
the 21 foot rule it is one thing to read
about the 21 foot rule it's another way
to actually see it done many times
people think that they will shoot as
well
under stress as they do in the range so
this whole thing
usually not the case i wanted people to
better visualize the
twiller tooler drill and 21 foot rule
contact us for demos your officers might
take the 21
foot rule more seriously the 21 foot
rule states that the average person
with a bladed weapon can run and cut you
in about the same amount of time that
the average person
can draw and shoot a gun that's
[ __ ] utter horseshit i mean i drew
guns before and it was way quicker than
this guy
with these [ __ ] jorts on or running
demonstrates that bladed weapons are
very dangerous especially against
cardboard targets well okay
this is a joke let me let's read about
the 21 foot rule let's see this is a
website 21footroll.com
unprepared the impossible odds against
the concealed carrier
oh oh there's more 20 21 foot rule with
a sword
these guys are amazing
he's dead he'd die no way
that guy's dead draws it
bang dead 100 dead no doubt that guy
would die immediately
bang bang bang bang bang bang he get
three steps bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang you get you go the whole thing
reclip bang bang bang bang bang you keep
on [ __ ] hitting them
unbelievable dude i l guys with swords
are great if you have a sword you're
great
it's over dude it's over for you
you're just the guy you're outdated you
understand
you know how you're outdated only guy
only white guys
own swords that's how you're outdated
unless you're talking about the [ __ ]
country side of japan you know asians
have swords but
that's how you know they're outdated
because ancient japanese [ __ ]
and also white guys white guys are done
you know that right you know white guys
are done
hey you know white guys are done
that's it they're gonna make a [ __ ]
movie about buzz aldrin and they're
gonna
you know the [ __ ] uh it's going to be
a biopic and it's
they're going to have a an indian lady
play him white guys
done so and this guy that's how you know
like you ever see a black guy with a
[ __ ] sword no
because they're out busy [ __ ] getting
jobs
white dudes are like i can't because why
because because of diversity
okay all right cool fine well i'll see
you later
sheath and then walk away we're done
that's how you know
swords are outdated white guys only have
them
um yeah dude
uh
coughed i um
i did uh i've been watching this gordon
ramsay
uh thing on uh
what do you call it i think it's on hulu
oh this is the gordon ramsay thing you
sent it to me oh okay
is this him gagging
dude let me just say this all right i'm
watching gordon ramsay hell on wheels
don't know how i got on it
i just started watching it gordon ramsay
talks really good [ __ ]
like he just talks such good [ __ ]
like be like
someone will say good evening and it'll
be like well it's an evening isn't it
but
i'd leave the good out and you're just
like how the [ __ ] did he think of that
so quickly
you know um
you've got potatoes in between your ears
do you have
it's not much of a dance floor just
looks like something you trip on
it's a hazard you're stupid that's why
sometimes it's just [ __ ] he just
throws all the insults
those other like the the the slams and
just
immediate name calling which is my
favorite thing
you know they cut out all the [ __ ]
bad [ __ ] too like now
there could never be a gordon ramsay now
this [ __ ] he started like 2005
was when he started getting famous or
something never now
that's because you're a [ __ ]
it would be like this is a test
but he um
i i [ __ ] the first episode is
hilarious dude
season one it's hell on wheels and he
goes and he [ __ ]
basically goes undercover
because people know he's gordon ramsey
so he goes undercover he gets like it's
like the [ __ ]
somebody in hollywood puts makeup all on
him and he'll go in as like a [ __ ]
longshoreman that's american and with a
hat on
on a phone and he goes and sits down in
waters and they give him food and
there's like people from like
across the way like filming him and he's
eating the like
let's get the oyster he's got people
with them because they order because
they'll recognize his voice and the
oysters get everything a bunch of
different [ __ ]
and then he starts eating it and then
and then and
and and my favorite thing is he'll
[ __ ] spit it out like
how many times in your life have you
spit out food in any restaurant ever
zero zero zero times you just [ __ ]
suck it up and eat it you know what i'm
talking about
unless it's vile so he'll go to like
restaurants
and he'll he'll have his team there
going and filming secretly
for like weeks it's like this whole
undercover operation and then he shows
up with a fake nose and a beard
in like overalls
and then he'll just like pop up and be
like
everyone knocks and forks down
first of all imagine you're just eating
at a restaurant
and somebody just stands up looking like
i mean he dressed like a [ __ ]
revolutionary war uh
larper once with his team everybody
knives
forks utensils down you'd hit the
[ __ ] deck
i'd [ __ ] myself oh god it's a civil war
all over again oh wait hold on i'm on
the right side
i'm on the safe side um
but this happens and people are like
what
and then he's like as he's taking his
nose off
and hat i have eaten
some pretty bad [ __ ]
but this absolutely is the worst
meal i've ever had in my entire
[ __ ] life and i'm
55 years old and by the end of him
talking
it's gordon ramsay and all of his makeup
and noses are on the ground
and everyone's like oh come on man
and then he says everyone get get i want
you
to get everybody out of the kitchen and
come back inside i wanna have a chat
with everyone
and they just [ __ ] do it
did if i owned the restaurant and some
dude did that to me i don't give a [ __ ]
if it's gordon ramsay or not i go like
this
hey man you have a lot of explaining to
do let's go outside but everyone's just
like oh gordon ramsay's here let me go
get everybody
hey they go in the kitchen they're like
go ramsay's here we gotta go outside
i think and then you say what were you
talking about is it i don't know but
it's not good
dude this is your place
this is your restaurant and you're
acting like you're in [ __ ] mode dude
imagine you woke up one day and gordon
ramsay was next to you
instead of your wife and he was just
like had makeup around his face
that looked like your wife and you're
like wait a second he's like
get up you've been sleeping in way too
late often taking care of the baby
everyone out to the kitchen now and
you're just like
okay we gotta get down let me call my
real wife hey babe i'm not gonna be
coming home for 24 hours he wants to fix
us
are you kidding me you'd say yo let's go
outside
this is insane no i have been tracking
the inside of your house
for three weeks we've got it all on
video you're doing everything wrong
and they'll say this to the people in
the restaurant you're doing everything
wrong and they got like surveillance
and it's like you've got nine rats
food that's owed reheated you got tacos
from a party that you're trying to put
on the menu
of the [ __ ] cooks has down syndrome
you don't even know
and he's the best cook
get out to the kitchen everybody out
even more the customers are just like
like it's a [ __ ] high school theater
play
who's the weak link like it's game of
thrones
i just want to be like hold up relax the
first episode was great because it was
the most italian dude of all time they
were into an italian restaurant with the
most italian dude of all time
and the lady in it was like we've had
this restaurant for a long time
and you know it was inherited from my
father
frankie and um
it was given my grandfather vinnie died
gave it to frankie and now frankie runs
it with my husband
my father frankie runs it with my
husband frankie they're both named
frankie
oh it's italian then frankie comes out
he's like
yeah what's going on and [ __ ] um
and gordon ramsay's like this is
terrible
and the italian guy's like all right let
me ask you a question
like right away hot like an italian and
i love it dude because that's my family
all right let me ask you a question
he says how big hold on how big is the
chip on your shoulder
and the guy's like let me answer the
question how big a chip i gotta be
how big of a chip do i gotta have how
big of a chip should i have
my father died i'm feeling my father
every day
how big of a chip do i have to have he's
like
listen do you want more up or not and
then he just softens
immediately flips that italian switch to
off
which is less emotional but also more
emotional and he says
i need more to my life
dude it's so funny dude
i love it because he thinks he knows
more than f oh dude
apparently this is it and if it's not
i'm going to be very mad at christmas
i'm amazed you can stand up straight
the size of the chip on your shoulder
here it is what size chip should i have
let me just take [ __ ]
what size chip should i have let me just
ask you
dude that's amazing is it the chip on
your shoulder so
what size chip should i have let me just
say actually as a [ __ ] mic
my dad put a million dollars into the
place and i'm failing what chip do you
want on
no restaurant no chip no chip
because if you're not in that fit state
of mind to respect what little customers
you have you shouldn't be [ __ ] in
here
okay it's italian shut it down
walls are up i'm gonna give you all that
you got
got i'm gonna give you all i ain't got
got i'm gonna give it to you in a short
amount of time
and after that the walls are coming up
and i'm shut down
you understand me
i blew my [ __ ] ear out over here
that's great
it blew it out that's how that's how i
get when i'm italian dude when i
i'm gonna tie in i yell i blew the
[ __ ] air out or the beats [ __ ]
not pill the beats headphones it's all
good i hear it on the right side
it's all good i and it's all better it's
all better
one fire fixed it one higher
okay okay the walls the way the walls
went up
were quicker than the [ __ ] star wars
doors no chip
because if you're not in that fit state
of mind to respect what little customers
you have
you shouldn't be [ __ ] in here okay
period
okay oh shut up i've got a question for
both of you here we go you want my help
yes or no
look yes i do
i needed more than my life ah seen so
many movies
life is a movie for this guy guy watches
de niro movies and you're like i mean
that's me
you know i would do that [ __ ]
[ __ ] jerk yeah dude [ __ ] yeah dude
italians are where it's at
[ __ ] jerk off throwing [ __ ] plates
dude i love it i feel home there
hey a [ __ ] jerk off yeah you [ __ ]
jerk off
the other guy that's the other guy
yeah dude throwing plates i'm [ __ ]
stuck here
yes destroying mine a monologue
in streetcar named desire dude i'm
[ __ ] stuck here
destroying my family and in the meantime
everyone else is just like
look you're just serving veal
just it's not that it's it's just like
it's as big it's as bad as you make it
i'm stuck here i'm destroying
my family through this uncooked veal
my dad gave me a million dollars do you
know what it's like
to fail your fat every day chip on the
shoulders the size of montana
[ __ ] you i love how italian [ __ ]
stuck
here destroying your mind this is what
you wanted this is what you're doing
it's my dream i [ __ ] everybody i live
with that every day
i'm [ __ ] believable wow
wow let me tell you something here we go
even though it may appear that all of
you have given up
yeah maybe i'm bitter cut them off dude
the italian way
the italian way even though
it seems that all of you have given up
i'm here to question gordon
you you can say a lot of things about me
i'ma cheat
i'm a liar i'm a race car driver and i'm
a card collector
i also do stamps but one thing you can't
tell me is i ain't never given up
oh dude italian's got to live with
everything every day you know what i
mean god damn it they put the baggage on
them
and i got to live with that every day i
got to live with that
every day
sir are you you're next i believe
he's at subway sorry it's just sometimes
i get the wrong bread you know i go home
i gotta live with that every day
sir i think they're calling you i think
your thing that's ready great i would
like an oatmeal cookie as well please
thank you you guys have good cookies for
some reason
dude i gotta live with that every day i
want to go see dude where's my car in
the theater
i walked out halfway through i gotta
live with that every day
or every day of my life so how big of a
chip on my shoulder am i supposed to
have
believable let me tell you something
when it cuts them off
even though it may appear that all of
you have given up maybe i'm bitter
hateful and disgusted inside and it
shows
that's what i never gave up don't say i
didn't street car name desire
dude he's crying here's the thing man
italians when you call
italians something they'll [ __ ] tell
you three things that they are
but then they'll disagree with you about
the one thing that you called them
it's the most amazing it is the most
italian thing you could [ __ ] do
well you [ __ ] lied vinnie you're
technically a lied i'll tell you what
i may be a disgusting piece of [ __ ]
i may be 45 pounds over [ __ ] weight
and i may also have taken some flying
lessons
but one thing i'm not is a goddamn liar
and you're just like just save it vinny
i'mma list two three things right now
that i am
that you didn't mention and then i'm
gonna bring it back home
okay i'm gonna talk about the thing that
you said i was
he's gonna forget about it i'm gonna
bring it back home
it's gonna make it seem like i got more
validity in there
you know when the pendulum swings you
understand
vinnie vinnie you're very emotional i
may work part-time at sea world
okay i may have hair
that of a lesbian woke liberal
okay and they may not be able to
moonwalk for [ __ ]
but one thing i'm not is emotional do
you understand me
it's disgusting behavior vinnie jeffrey
he goes on
with his hands and now he the whole
thing about the titans is you shift the
emotion
you scream and then you soften it up you
know
that's like everyone think the al pacino
that's the thing that [ __ ] it up
that's the thing that [ __ ] up italians
is al pacino's acting
in the godfather when she was like when
the when the
when the [ __ ] wife of albacino was
good you know she's going to go in and
ask him
if he had the the hit put out on her
[ __ ] dad or whatever it is
and she's like did you have the hip put
out on on my dad and he's just and you
think pacino's gonna be like
oh you [ __ ] oh you don't ask oh
you don't thought oh you don't [ __ ]
do this
and i'll put you sitting on a [ __ ]
desk with his hands in his pockets
and takes a long beat and he says don't
ever ask me about my business kate
he [ __ ] it up for the rest of the
generations to go
before that italians were just [ __ ]
screaming everything your father every
day
here we go it's disgusting behavior
vinny
jeffy you ever feel your father every
day
did you i'm answering your question my
father died 20 years ago
slammed do you have a fight
you have do you ever feel your father
every day
i'm mixing your questions you have a
[ __ ] job
my father has been dead for 20 years
okay i'm very sorry for that because dad
and mom mean everything to me
if if you failed your father every day
let me say it the right way would you
feel good about every day going to work
if would you i'm asking you a question
trying to take i like how he's trying to
take the
conversation home with him you
understand
oh just going ramsey you think you're
gonna ask me something i gotta ask you
some i gotta ask you a few things
why do you feel about failing your
father huh
and what's that i have no idea it's been
like five six years five or six years
probably because i made two years i was
here before i got in stay there two
seconds what's in this one
what the [ __ ] is that this was from a
party really wanted me to save it it's a
tilapia
cook tilapia yep and he brings it back
and
freezes it is he seriously asking to put
that on the menu table he wants me to
reuse him i throw him away behind his
back
throw him away say that start tying the
whole family starting throw them away
i'm gonna throw him away
dude throw
yay boy back from a party every time i
go behind his back a tram away
dude this is i cannot believe how
[ __ ] italian this family is i just
cannot believe it dude
there's they gotta have like two two
three guys named butch in here
it's unbelievable i want this whole clip
yeah he goes there's nothing wrong with
this which is where some of the
arguments are where the argument stops
like when the argument starts right it
says
when i start we escalate there we go so
then we got then we come this way
there's more now stop you want to shoot
it walking look at this
welcome to [ __ ] hell wow this is a
walking
can you smell that oh yeah such a deal
such a dick that that's real how old is
that
uh
i don't know how that looks like this
and i don't know how this got in here so
take that [ __ ] thing out
so italian what is this a dressing
that's not the dressing for today
the other one that is black and mold
just unreal yeah garbage what is this
dead monkey this is [ __ ] obscene what
is this oh
that's a that's the monkey we had from
the children's party
we we i was looking for that actually to
be honest i don't know how it got in
there
we we must be [ __ ] vinny wanted to
keep it for something
maybe i think what he wanted to do is
cut the legs off and use them as a wish
thing give a wish on it maybe for good
luck or something like that
i really don't understand let's go ask
vinnie hey vinnie hey vinny what are
these
monkey paws for makes a question
i got four monkey paws all right you
calling me
a monkey order i may be
early on in my life an insurance
salesman i may have been
a lightweight training boxer that never
made it
and i may have eyebrows that connect if
i don't pluck them
but one thing i'm not is a monkeyboard
can you smell that yeah i could i could
smell it from here
so dip jesus it's about to throw up hey
come here
put it there bring that here bring the
hair oh my god
i said there's something they said
they're saying stench of stink and
[ __ ] disgusting smell that for me the
whole [ __ ] place contamination
take it away
yeah we threw it up ew we are [ __ ]
wow absolutely that's the worst walking
here we go i've ever [ __ ] witnessed
what a dick
you have lost [ __ ] control what a
dick i'm getting [ __ ] out of here
what a dick and you're short i hope my
dad makes these changes last because
it'll have so and you're short did you
did you know that you're too short
can barely reach the [ __ ] dressing
you're a short [ __ ] guy
[Laughter]
dude gordon ramsay's such a dick i love
it
what is this is the worst walk-in closet
i've ever seen in my [ __ ] life look
at this smell this
smells like [ __ ] the inside of my
anus after i haven't [ __ ]
wiped and haven't showered all day and
after i just took a [ __ ]
all right it's absolutely terrible and
look at these peaches over here
they're so bad when you eat them it
makes you literally feel
bad about yourself it's like a mental
thing it doesn't even taste bad just
hours later it puts you in a depression
and it makes you feel like you didn't
amount to anything in your life
all right we're out of here you've got
to fix this you're also too short
you're a short guy get the keys to my
car gets in a [ __ ]
lambo you could never afford this
for the restaurant for my family 24
hours for me but
all in all i think i grew up the
italians just think their whole life is
a movie it's amazing dude
by the way also if gordon ramsay is in
the [ __ ] thing you don't have to say
it contains strong language or like
warning this
this clip contains uh whatever the [ __ ]
strong language okay cool uh i talked
about [ __ ] three things so far this
podcast and we're 50 minutes in
so i don't know what the [ __ ] you know
guys hey you know sometimes we do it
long for them we do it long foreign am i
babies
we do it long form i'm a long-form
podcaster
my goal is to [ __ ] tell you a story
once for an hour long and that's it
bro how many how many [ __ ]
running a restaurant is like gotta be
one of the hardest things and it's so
something that guys who [ __ ] are like
fail at everything things that they can
do you know it's like that's one of
those things that like
is like being a comedian like there are
so many guys that just get on stage that
are
that are like all right
nothing else worked out i guess i'll go
up there and tell jokes and you're just
like
oh you don't get it you don't get it
it's too hard it's so hard
to try and [ __ ] do stand up and
become successful
and not get cancelled you know what i
mean and like i'm sorry little kids
hey guys that's it for youtube if you
want to see the rest of the episode head
on over to our patreon
uh where you could get the rest of the
episode and it's uncut and all that it's
it's over at patreon.comcrystalia
and it's also got other stuff like the
back episodes that you missed out only
on patreon you get access
to all that and also other things that
uh i put up
um that is exclusive to patreon so i
appreciate you uh
either way but uh thanks thanks again
[Music]
congratulations
thank you
[Music]
i'm rolling rolling rolling
taking liberties